I also want to play some
comment from Carrie Lee,
former Arizona gubernatorial candidate.
I want to get your take,
actually multiple
takes on what these comments mean
and how closely they're being monitored.
Take a listen.
We are we're at war, people.
If you want to get to President Trump,
you're going to have to go through me
and you're going to have to go through.
75 million Americans just like me.
And I'm going to tell you, yet
most of us are Card-Carrying
members of the NRA.
That's not a threat.
That's a public service announcement.
She says it's not a threat.
How does law enforcement
look at comments like that?
Are they a threat?
So law enforcement
looks and comments
like that is protected
by the First Amendment.
What they're looking for is the reaction
to those comments
on the other side,
which is in the chat rooms
in the message boards.
Are people talking about,
let's get our guns, let's do something?
Remember
in Cincinnati, just days after the Mar
a Lago search warrant,
a guy with an AR 15
rifle came in and opened
fire on the FBI's office there
until he was killed in a shootout
with police.
So you've got the group saying
you've got the crowd thing,
but you've got the lone
wolf thing to consider in these factors.
And Florida is a funny place.
Under Governor
DeSantis,
they made it easier to carry guns.
You don't need a permit.
You can have concealed weapons,
but it's not an open carry state.
So you can't show up with your
AR 15 rifles in full uniform
or your pistols on your hip,
you know, and and fully exposed.
But there's a trick,
which is if you're
a hunter,
is on the way to a hunting thing,
or if you're fishermen going
fishing or
if you're a sportsman
on your way to target practice,
then you can.
So you've seen second
Second Amendment groups
do these gatherings
where they carry
their weapons in the open,
basically challenging law enforcement.
They're thinking about all of that.
I was fascinated
where you were going to go
after Florida is a funny place.
Well, this is what
this kind of follows
on what I was saying
earlier about the ways
we have all changed
in the last five years.
I talked about the courts
and the justice system,
how it is a little more fortified,
a little more understanding
of what it's dealing
with when Trump or a Trump case
comes knocking on its door.
It's the same thing with law enforcement
and the FBI. Wow.
What they learned a lesson
over the last couple of years
to listen to chatter,
to pass that chatter on,
to really take these kinds of comments
or and specifically
what's going on on social media
very seriously, where they can
obviously there's
discord channels and things like that
that are more low key
and harder to penetrate.
But we know they've been doing
more work in this area
because earlier
they talked about extremist
groups, Merrick Garland, etc.
And I think this is going
to be another example
of where
our system has been stress tested.
And we might see the reflection
of that over the next couple
and saw these play.
I think
and hope that the sentences,
the convictions and sentences
of some of the January six
rioters have sent a message.
I mean, one of the purposes
of our criminal justice system
and sentencing is deterrence.
You want to deter
the person who's being sentenced,
but others, too.
And you look at these sentences,
as John mentioned,
the leader of the Oath
Keepers got 18 years, Stewart Rhodes.
We've seen other sentences
11 years seven years.
These are real sentences.
And I hope that anyone
who's thinking of doing anything
takes note of Trump
has spoken out on behalf of rioters
who have been convicted.
At one point,
he tweeted an image of them
singing in jail,
Do you want to be singing
in prison for Trump?
I mean, that's a cool tweet,
but I don't know if people want to
lay things down on the line.
We can't forget on our own town
hall meeting he was asked,
would you pardon all of these people
if you were reelected?
And he said they were.
They came with love.
Yeah. Yeah.
I don't know if that's what resonates
with people,
you know,
counting on whether Donald Trump
is going to get elected again.
I'm going to end up in the White House
again.
He's going to potentially pardon you
or if they are looking at, you know,
what happened in the wake of January six,
if that does serve as a deterrent,
you know,
one thing
that has been striking to me
is how many of the sort of the same
players are popping up.
Again, we're talking
about the Proud Boys.
Again,
I was listening to an interview Roger
Stone did with Donald Trump yesterday
again, another player
talking about the supporters
that are going to be there
in Miami to stand for Donald Trump.
And then Roger Stone is quick to say,
but we're assembling peacefully.
People are going to be
assembling peacefully.
So we'll see if that resonates.
Carlos, we're hearing bellicose rhetoric
coming from the president, members
of some members of Congress,
some of his allies.
How is that
that rhetoric, that online bluster,
how is it impacting
the law enforcement reaction
Well, the
law enforcement
agents across South Florida
are taking all of that into account.
In conversations
I had with folks
within the Miami Dade Police Department,
they told me that they were aware
of some of these social media posts.
They were keeping
a close eye on the rhetoric
that was being used
not only on social media,
but by some of these elected officials.
Over the weekend,
the former Republican candidate
for governor in Arizona, Carrie Lee,
she made some comments
about the indictment
that have
brought a great deal of criticism her way
for some of the language she used.
Here's a portion of what
she said over the weekend.
We are we're at war.
People
If you want to get to President Trump,
you're going to have to go through me
and you're going to have to go
through 75 million Americans just like me
and I'm going to tell you. Yet
most of us
are Card-Carrying members of the NRA.
And so, Jake,
the Miami-Dade Police Department
tells me they are in communications
with the Department of Homeland Security,
and they're keeping
a close eye on two events
that they have pretty much
confirmed are taking place.
One is happening right now
outside of the Trump Doral property here,
where some supporters have gathered.
They're holding up signs and
and waving the U.S.
flag, as well as some posters
supporting the former president.
And we're told that
they're also keeping a close eye
on some protests
that will most likely
take place tomorrow.
Outside of the federal courthouse
in downtown Miami.
All right.
Carlos Suarez in Doral, Florida, thank
you so much.